يحثوا محرز الخطى امام مستشفى الاطفال
بتونس العاصمه لاخذ الدواء اللازم لزوجته
وابنته حديثه الولاده وبعد طول انتظار
يعود بيد فارغه واخرى لا شيء فيها عليه ان
يبحث عن الدواء في الصيدليات الخاصه عله
يظفر
من هكذا
احنا كل شيء مش موجوده
في تونس تتعمق اكثر خاصه مع توقفي موزعي
الادويه بالجمله عن نقل الادويه في مختلف
انحاء البلاد باستثناء الضروريه منها بعد
خلاف مع السلطات حول نسب الارباح ما يعني
توقف تزويد الصيدليات بنسبه 99%
ايقاف هذا
تدريجيا على عمليه التزاوج بتاع صيدليات
اليوم
لكن معاه الايام القادمه الاس- الازمه مش
تشتد جدا ومن هنا للاخر الاسبوع ما نتصورش
كلمه ازاي لصيدليه تلقى فيها احتياجات
المواطنين
توقفه وموزعي الادويه بالجمله عن النشاط
يمثل ضربه مذيعه اخرى للقطاع الصحي المثقل
بمشاكلها هيكليه واخرى مستجده هكذا يؤكد
متابعون مع تصاعد التحذيرات من احتقان
الوضع الاجتماعي جراءه
في قطاعات حيويه وحساسه
الاجتماعيه
الا بعد اتفاق السلطات مع موازيعي الادويه
لانضاف الى اضرابات اخرى بعد توقف في لغه
الحوار بين الحكومه واتحاد الشغل في
قطاعات النقل والمخابز والكهرباء والتعليم
وغيرها الوضع الاجتماعي خطير يقول متابعون
تم التغيير حقيقي داخل المجتمعات تونسي
اليوم ليس فقط اتحاد الشغل من يقود
الاضرابات حتى القطاع الخاص واصحاب
المؤسسات دخلوا ايضا على خط الاحتجاج وهذا
ينظر ليس فقط شتاء ساخن ولكن شتاء قد يفضي
الى مواجهه لا تحمد عقباها بين السلطه
وبين عموم التونسيين وفي ظل هذه الظروف
الاستثنائيه تعد تونس العده لاجراء
الاستحقاق التشريعيه في انتظار الحصول من
عدمه على قرض من صندوق النقد الدوليه
لانعاش الاقتصاد وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس